parmi les députés de la CAQ Luc
provençale et le seul qui ose le dire
donc c'est sûr que personnellement je ne
déception autrement les questions sur
l'abandon de la portion autoroutière du
troisième lien sont plutôt esquivés pour
l'instant bonjour
demain puis après je vois commenter tant
que vous voulez même ericaire qui avait
mis son siège en jeu pour le troisième
lien refuse de commenter je vais laisser
madame Gilmour
est-ce que vous allez vous en parler
après jamais la carte n'avait envisagé
que le troisième lien soit réservé aux
transports collectif potentiellement
pour une ligne de tramway François
Legault l'admet la décision a été
difficile à prendre il faut toujours
travailler pour le bien des Québécois
quand une situation change faut avoir
l'humilité changer selon le Premier
ministre les études qui seront dévoilées
jeudi vont démontrer que les besoins ne
sont plus les mêmes depuis la pandémie
il y a pas eu seulement des changements
du côté du télé il y a eu aussi des
changements du côté des voyagements en
auto durant les heures de pointe ce
serait de l'aveuglement volontaire et du
nityan que de faire semblant que la
pandémie a pas eu d'incidence sur le
quotidien des gens à Québec le maire
Bruno marchand se réjouit de cette
volte-face et salut le courage de la
ministre je pense que c'est
extraordinaire pour les vies c'est
extraordinaire pour Québec c'est
extraordinaire pour les gens de la
région pour cette force économique qu'on
veut créer ici mais de l'autre côté du
fleuve le préfet de belles chasses ne
mange pas ses mots à l'égard du
gouvernement puis nous dit tout le temps
quand c'est vous peut-être on va vous le
faire le troisième lien on arrive avec
ça une plaque en pleine face
c'est très ordinaire la confiance envers
le gouvernement elle vient de tomber bas
en juin il s'est entêté dans un projet
qui était basé sur rien à part des
fantaisies électorales François Legault
on a fait une position fort il y a roulé
tout le monde dans la farine François
Legault parce qu'on nous a dit des
choses pour obtenir notre vote en
sachant très bien quelques mois plus
tard on allait faire l'inverse le projet
de tramway même si la scandale est
encore plus bas que le salaire affecté
encore plus le transport en commun la
pandémie comment ça se fait que sur le
tramway ça n'affecte pas la décision
mise à part les conservateurs tous les
parties d'opposition salut le retrait du
tunnel autoroutier mais aucun ne veut
donner de chèques en blanc au
gouvernement parce que trop de questions
restent en suspens comme le moyen de
transport collectif qui sera choisi le
tracé final et le coût du projet ici
alexandre Duval Radio-Canada Québec